so uh we're going to talk about primes
again we know we love primes and there's
all different types of primes we know
there's infinitely many primes where
there's all little different categories
of primes so i'm going to show you
another one it's called wilson primes
there's only three
wilson primes that we know of uh so
let's just write out the three wilson
primes i'll show you why these are
special types of primes five thirteen
and five hundred and sixty-three
now actually they think there's
infinitely many wilson primes but we've
only found three of them so what's this
the special thing that they do that
other primes don't well one thing that
all primes do i'll show you this this is
what all primes can do you have a prime
p
minus one we're going to do a factorial
on it uh do you remember factorial so
you're multiplying all the numbers up to
and including
p minus one it'd be one times two times
three times four so if my prime is five
uh it'd be one times two times 3 times 4
okay am i going to add 1
and that is divisible
by the original prime p
all primes do that so in the case of 5
you would have 5 minus one factorial
uh plus one so what's that as we're
talking four factorial plus one what is
four factorial it's one times two times
three times four
and then we add the one on uh that's 24.
uh so it's 24 plus 1 is 25
and you can divide by 5. in fact you can
do that for any prime that will work for
any prime and it only works for primes
it doesn't work for composite numbers
we've talked about tests for primes
before um we talked about firm our
primes and sometimes there were liars
weren't there there were some numbers
that weren't prime that passed the test
they were lying to us
this is a 100
test for primes only primes pass it
composites fail
let's have a let's do a composite can i
choose one oh you're going to pick a big
one we have to do a factorial remember
this is the problem let's can i let's do
uh eight
right so eight minus one
factorial then we add one right
so seven factorial
uh plus one okay so we're going to do
seven factorial uh so that is i wonder
what that is um
5040.
i don't i don't show them that
so 5040 plus one
so 5041
but i'm saying that's never going to be
divisible by eight
uh i don't think it's going to be is it
so we're going to divide that by eight
and it's not so you don't get a full
number whole number for that
so and that's guaranteed primes will
give you a whole number and composites
would never give you a whole number for
that uh yeah that's called wilson's
theorem and it is a test for primes it's
not a great test for primes because you
have to do a factorial and they get
massive so you'd have to work out a
massive factorial if it passes though it
is a prime so all primes pass that test
the wilson primes are special because
they pass the test twice over you can
actually do it twice over so you can
divide by the prime and then divide by
the prime again and you get a whole
number so all primes passed the test
once but only these three that we found
managed to do that twice over
uh i'll show you one let's do the five
well we did the five already didn't we
so
we got 25
1 factorial plus 1. so we end up with
25. so we know you can divide by 5. so
you know 25 divided by 5 is equal to 5.
and all i'm saying is you can divide by
the prime again
so obviously 5 divided by 5 is 1 so that
would work other primes wouldn't do that
so we see a prime passing it once and
then failing the second time i want to
see 13. do you want to do 13 first yeah
let's do it with 13 see what we get so
we're looking at 12 factorial plus 1
let's see what you've got
uh 12
factorial brilliant big number
479 million
1 600
plus 1
plus 1.
all right
let's see if the prime divides it
do you think it's likely
divide it by thirteen
yep it divides perfectly wonderful but
all primes do that does it do it
twice yes it does
it does it twice
so
13 is a wilson prime
as is the last one i've got here 563.
do you want to see something fail just
to check yeah yeah pick a prime uh seven
yes let's do seven let's do seven small
isn't it right first i work out how to
clear
that's that one right seven so we need
seven minus one factorial and then we're
gonna add one so we're talking six
factorial plus one
well i know six factorial is 720
if i feel confident i'm going to say
that's 721.
let's see if it works now if i divide by
7 which is the prime
works 103
can i do it second time i don't think
it's going to happen though
divide by 7 again then
and and no it's not going to work
so there so that's the that's kind of
nice it's nice nice little um prime
number fact there's no great use for it
but why do we have to do everything for
application this is just a great little
prime number fact now that we know what
wilson primes are um let's have a look
here about of the wilson
lemma that was that was just the
original result that was just this one
here so i'm saying that primes
can do this at least once let's just see
if that's true so we're going to prove
that so we're going to get some more
brown paper
those sneaky composite numbers
no counter example to this and they've
checked
large numbers for this